well for 80 years the Democratic Party
was the party of FDR it saw itself as a
champion of America's working class in
some ways it was today's Democrats feel
differently about their constituency the
top part of the Democratic Party today
appears to be mass immigration the
displacement of existing workers here
with an unending glut of foreign workers
many of the Democratic Party argued for
a shutdown of the government in pursuit
of full daca amnesty House Minority
Leader Nancy Pelosi even said the
parents of dreamers did quote a great
thing by breaking our immigration laws
martin O'Malley was a Democratic
governor of melody recently started a
PAC to help down ballot Democrats he's
gonna be one of the people charting the
future of the Democratic Party and he
joins us tonight tell us what it is
governor great to see you Thank You
Tucker good to be with you thanks for
having me Mary so it's C it seems to me
Merry Christmas it seems to me that the
election of Trump opens up you know a
bunch of questions for Democrats obvious
one is who are we gonna be reclaim our
place as the party of the middle class
or not I think they could probably do
pretty well if they did that but that's
not obvious from the priorities why
would the Democratic Party put amnesty
for daca recipients at the very top of
the list of things to get done at the
end of the year look I think that I
think the core of the Democratic Party
who remains that commitment to that
timeless American ideal of opportunity
for all and were we not a country of
immigrants we would not be the country
of creativity innovation diversity which
makes us which makes us such a strong
country so look the Democratic Party
believes in the dignity of every person
in the dignity of work and contrary to
some false assertions there is not a lot
of mass immigration going on I mean last
year net immigration from Mexico was
zero meaning that as many people left as
no no no no there has been mass
immigration for 52 years and has
completely changed the demographic mix
of the country in the population of the
country we have more than a million
coming Tamika Lee right but not at these
levels we've actually never had levels
this high in American history that's a
fact
oh and so by and by
are you against immigration on I'm just
sayin 1070 was in the 18 we have a
higher a higher proportion now but
here's the point if you're worried about
wages which are stagnant and that seems
like an obvious issue for Democrats and
something to be upset about importing a
million low-wage workers every year does
not make wages go up it's just a math
question it doesn't work so why would
they be for that yeah here's the rub
though Tucker it's an it's if you have
people in our country already in these
DREAM Act kids the kids covered by Daka
they were brought here at a time when
they weren't even of an age of reason
when they could say whether they wanted
to come right or didn't want to come so
the only country they've known is the
United States what's a real drag on
wages is when you force people to live
in the shadows of a society to work off
the books to be exploited because they
cannot go to to enforce contracts and
they cannot and they're susceptible to
being taken advantage of these are the
things that holds hold down wages when
we say you're saying buying open society
by giving for all of us amnesty to
people bringing more immigrants in who
are coming from countries where the
average wage is 1/3 or less than what it
is here that will somehow magically make
wages in this country go up why hasn't
that happened yet if that works out what
I'm saying is this what I'm saying is
this that these kids are already here
they have been here for four years and
years the only country they know is the
United States right now I guess it's a
tough situation for them but like of all
the issues I don't know how about
entitlement cuts or the opioid crisis or
things that actually affect middle class
America why is the one issue they're not
going to move on they'll shut the
government down over it 700,000 people
here illegally it just seems like the
middle class is not their priority you
see what I'm saying I see what you're
saying but I think you're I think you
ascribe to the Democratic Party you know
a myopic worldview I mean these kids are
important the fact that 120 of them are
falling out of status every day is also
important but the most simple we also
the Democratic Party was fighting
against this
1.3 trillion dollar tax cut that
primarily benefits the wealthy that
isn't needed that isn't fiscally
responsible that does nothing to make
wages go up Democratic Party is
advocating in states and cities across
America for raising the minimum wage for
paying a living wage
look we're also advocating for more
affordable college more affordable
health care so yes part of that is that
we care about these kids these kids
whose only country is the United States
of America I know I think it's about
this part about the kids governor thank
you thank you and Merry Christmas
remember Jesus was himself a refugee
child what would you do if he came to
your border
that's a stupid it's our dirt spot thank
you though